شهر يوليو 2020 12 بحث صادم في المجله
الامريكيه لعلم الاوبئه عنوانه الضغط
المالي ومحاولات الانتحار في عينه تمثيليه
وطنيه من البالغين في الولايات المتحده
البحث كشف ان الاشخاص اللي بيعانوا من
مشاكل الماليه بسبب الديون عرضه للانتحار
بمعدل 20 مره اكتر من الاشخاص اللي ما
عندهمش النوع ده من الضغوط ده واحد من
ابحاث كثيره بتربط بين الديون وبالانتحار
وبتثبت العلاقه بين الضغوط الماليه اللي
بتسببها الديون وبين اقبال الافراد على
الانتحار ربنا يعافينا جميعا اعتقد ان عدد
كبير مننا سمع عنه او عرف بحالات انتحار
بسبب الدوائق الماليه وكثره الديون
والاديان السماويه بروزه خطوره الدين على
الفرد نفسه وعلى اسرته وعلى المجتمع بشكل
عام الدين الاسلامي مثلا او لاهميه كبيره
لتوضيح مخاطر ان الشخص يكون مديون وشدد
سرعه قضاء الدين وحذر من عدم سداده او
المماطله في الثبات يكفي انك تعرف ان اطول
ايه في القران الكريم بتتكلم عن الدين
والنبيه محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
والذي نفسي بيده لو ان رجلا قتل في سبيل
الله ثم احيي ثم قتل ثم احيا ثم قتل وعليه
دين ما دخل الجنه حتى يقضى عنه دينه يعني
لو شخص استشهد ثلاث مرات وعليه دين مش
هيدخل الجنه الا لما يتم قضاء الدين ده
سواء في الدنيا من قبل اهله واصدقائهم
عارفه او في الاخره بعد القصاص منه ركز
معايا انا هنا مش بخوفك بقدر ما انا
بوضحلك خطوره الدين وطبعا كلامنا في
الحلقه دي متعلق بالديون السيئه حد
هيسالني هو في بين كويس ودين سيء يا اشرف
اقول له اه فيه مش كل الديون شر محض وان
شاء الله هنبقى نوضح في حلقه منفصله الفرق
بين النوعين دول من الديون لان ده مهم جدا
بس اللي عايزك تعرفه دلوقتي ان الدين
السيء هو اللي بيمنعك من الوصول لاهدافك
الماليه زي انك مثلا تشتري بيت او تتدخل
علشان تتجوز او تجيب حاجه لاسرتك او تكمل
تعليمك في معهد او جامعه مرموقه الدين
السيء هو اللي بيضيع عليك فرص كتير زي انك
تلاقي وظيفه احسن من اللي انت فيها مثلا
لانه بيكتفك ومش بيديك فرصه تدور على
وظيفه افضل او تطور مهاراتك الدين السيء
بيضيع عليك فرصه انك تبدا مشروع تجاري خاص
بيك لو ده مناسب لك يعني وهو اللي بيكون
مصدر للتوتر والحزن والاكتئاب وبيخليك
قلقان طول الوقت وبالتالي بياثر على صحتك
العقليه باختصار بيحطوا كل القيود على
حياتك وممكن يدمرها تماما عشان كده لازم
تسديده يكون اولويه ماليه قصوى ده شغلك
الشاغل ولازم نبدا نفعل مع بعض وضع
الطوارئ الماليه لحد ما نتخلص من الديون
السيئه دي علشان ترجع تسيطر على اموالك
تاني وتبدا المرحله التاليه وهي تكوين
الثروه سواء بسيطه او ضخم النهارده هنعرف
مع بعض في خطوات محدده ازاي نحط خطه
لتسديد الديون بتاعتنا وايه هي
استراتيجيات سداد الديون انا اشرف ابراهيم
المختل الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر منصه مستقل على رعايتها الحلقه
دي ومستقل بتقدم خدمات استشارات فتقدر
تستعين بمستشار مالي او مستشار اعمال من
عليها علشان يساعدك على التخطيط الجيد
لبدء نشاطك التجاري او تطوير نشاطك الحالي
او يساعدك على اداره اموالك والاستثمار
وتحقيق الحريه الماليه هتدخل على مستقل
هتلاقي صفحات المستقلين والخبراء اللي
تقدر توظفه هتكتم مستشار اعمال او مستشار
مالي هتلاقي اللي يقدر يساعدك في رابط
للمناصه في وصف الفيديو وفي تعليقات
فيسبوك يعني ايه دنيا يا جماعه الدين ده
هو لما شخص يقترض مال من شخص او من جهه
الفلوس دي مباشره بقى اسمها دين لحد ما
تسددها الدين ده ممكن يساعدك في تحسين
حياتك الماليه وممكن يدمر حياتك الماليه
طيب بنقدر نعرف ده ازاي من حاجتين الاولى
مقدار الدين اللي انت قادر تتحمله
والتانيه الغرض اللي انت استخدمت الدين
دافعي طب احنا ليه اصلا بنستدين لاننا
بنحتاج او بنرغب في شراء شيء ما بيكلف
اكتر من اللي بن ندفعوا كاش من فلوسنا او
احيانا بيكون عندنا قدره ماليه ندفع ثمن
الشيء ده ولكن عاوزين نشتري حاجه تانيه
بفلوسنا وبالتالي بنقترض علشان نمول عمليه
شراء معينه طبعا بيتم الاتفاق مع المقرض
على سداد الدين وفقا لجدول زمني معين
واحيانا بيكون مع فايده او رسوم معينه
بتضاف لمقدار الدين اللي انت اقترضته اول
حاجه محتاجين نعملها دلوقتي اننا نفهم نوع
الديون اللي علينا دي وتكونت ازاي ونعمل
لها حصر ده هيساعدنا في ايه اول حاجه في
خطه تسديد الديون تاني حاجه اننا نغير
العادات او الظروف اللي خلتنا مديونيه ودي
نقطه مهمه جدا يا اخواننا من اللحظه اللي
هتبدا فيها خطه تسديد الديون هتبقى مفعل
وضع الطوارئ الماليه زي ما قلنا حياتك
وعاداتك وسلوكياتك قبل تفعيل الخطه غير
بعدها تماما العادات والظروف والسلوكيات
الماليه اللي كونت عليك ديون مستحيل
نسيبها كده زي ما هي وبالتالي هتبقى مجبر
تقبل حاجات
مستحيل تقبلها في الظروف العاديه وانت ما
عندكش ديور وهتكون مجبر ترفض حاجات كان
مستحيل ترفضها في الظروف العاديه وانت ما
عندكش ديون لما نيجي نقرب من الديون
بتاعتنا ونفهم انواعها هنلاقي الشكل
الاشهر اللي بيسبب الديون هو الفروض ناس
كتير بتقترض في مراحل معينه من حياتها اما
علشان تفتح مشروع او تشتري سياره جديده او
تشتري عقار مثلا واحيانا بيقترضوا علشان
يشتروا حاجات اقل من كده زي تليفون مثلا
القروض دي ممكن تتحول لكابوس لو ما قدروش
يسددوا الاقساط بتاعتها وبالذات لو اسعار
الفائده عليها مرتفعه يعني مثلا المشروع
خسر وفضل لك القرض اللي لازم تسدده وانت
كنت عامل حسابك تسدد القرض من ارباح
المشروع او فجاه ما بقتش قادر تكمل اقساط
السياره فتضطر تبعها بخساره لان سعرها وهي
بقت مستعمله اقل من سعرها وهي جديده فتشيل
انت الفرق ده او عامل حسابك تدفع قسط
التليفون من مرتبك فجاه تحت من الشغل لا
قدر الله وبقيت بلا عمل كل دي ظروف بتحصل
معنا كلنا وبالتالي الديون دي بتبدا تضغط
على حياتنا الماليه وما بتخليناش قادرين
حتى على نفقات المعيشه بتاعتنا والخطير
بقى انها غالبا بتخلينا نتحمل ديون تانيه
لانك مش قادر تدفع فبتضطر تقترض او تستلف
علشان تسدد الدين الاولاني وتلاقي نفسك في
دايره لا تنتهي واحيانا الديون بتتراكم
علينا بسبب الظروف الطارئه اللي كلنا
بنواجهها سواء كانت طبيه او اسريه او في
الشغل والظروف الطارئه دي بتاكل دخلك
وبتترك تستلف او تقترض وبالتالي تتحمل
ديون وده شكل الديون التاني في بقى نوعيه
تالته من الديون بتنشق بسبب ان سيادتك
عايز تعيش في مستوى اعلى من امكانياتك
الماديه والديون دي بتنشا بسبب الانفاق
المتهور او غير المدروس علشان تبنبل
اصدقائك والمحيط بتاعك انك راجل ثري
فتشتري ايفون جديد بالقسط بالف دولار وانت
مرتبك 200 دولار بس او تشتري جهاز منزلي
غالي او ملابس غاليه من ماركات عالميه الى
اخره باختصار هي ديون بتتكون لما بتعيش
بما يتجاوز امكانياتك وده هيخليك تيجي في
مرحله ما من حياتك والديون دي تتراكم عليك
وتعجز عن السداد وهتبدا غرامات التاخير
تزيد وهتلاقي الديون اللي عليك بقت اكبر
بكثير من القيمه الفعليه للحاجات اللي انت
اشتريتها بالتالي المقصود من كل اللي فات
ده اننا لازم لازم نفهم نوعيه الديون اللي
علينا وتكونت ازاي ده هيساعدنا في وضع خطه
التخلص من الديون بعد كده محتاجين نعمل
قائمه بجميع الديون اللي علينا ونصنفها
ونكتب مواعيد لاستحقاق بتاعتها واسعار
الفائده اللي عليها اكتب ديونك بالتفصيل
وخليها قدامك واحنا بنعمل الخطوه المهمه
والخطيره اللي هنعملها دلوقتي دي هنعمل
ايه بقى بعد كده قبل ما اكمل بس الشباب
هنا بيقولولي اني نسيت افكركم في المقدمه
الاشتراك في القناه لان اشتراككم بيخلينا
نكمل من المحتوى بتاعنا فضروري تشتركوا لو
عايزين تدعموا القناه خلاص كتبت ديونك
وحطيتها قدامك ايه هي الخطوه المهمه
والخطيره الخطوه هي اننا نعمل ميزانيه
مستحيل نقدر نسدد ديونك من غير ميزانيه
وهتعرف دلوقتي ليه الحقيقه يا جماعه
الطبيعي والمفترض اصلا في الاوقات العاديه
اننا نعمل ميزانيه سواء علينا ديون او لا
لكن احتياجنا للميزانيه واحنا مفعلين وضع
الطوارئ الماليه وعاوزين نتخلص من ديونا
بيكون اشد كمان مش عاوزكم تتخضوا من كلمه
ميزانيه موضوع بسيط خالص الميزانيه
باختصار بتوضح حاجتين بيدخل لك فلوس قد
ايه وبتصرف فلوس قد ايه وفي ايه وبالتالي
علشان نعمل ميزانيه لازم الاول نكتب الدخل
بتاعنا والدخل ده بيشمل اي فلوس بتدخل لنا
سواء بقى من مرتب او مهجرين شقه محل ارض
مثلا او صافي ربح بيدخل لنا من مشروع معين
مثلا كل ده لازم يتكتب في قائمه الدخل
ونجمع الرقم في الاخر الكلام ده يا
اخواننا ما لوش علاقه بمقدار دخلك صعب
تقبض 1000 او مليون ما لوش علاقه لازم
تعمله الحاجه الثانيه بنوضح النفقات
بتاعتنا بالتفصيل بنصرف كام وفي ايه
بالظبط هنقسم النفقات بتاعتنا لفئتين
مصروفات الالزاميه
ومصروفات اختياريه
المصروفات الالزاميه اللي لازم تدفع زي
مثلا الايجار في الخدمات زي الكهرباء
والميه والغاز والانترنت الطعام البقاله
الضروريه المواصلات من البيت للشغل والعكس
الادويه تعليم الاطفال ورعايتهم المصروفات
الاختياريه اللي نقدر نعيش من غيرها زي
مثلا الاكل بره البيت اشتراكات خدمات بس
الفيديو اشتراك في موقع او مجله نادرا ما
بتدخلوا اشتراك الجيم اللي بتروح مره في
الشهر الملابس الانشطه الترفيهيه من اول
القعده على القهوه تحت البيت لحد الرحلات
العنايه الشخصيه كماليات او ديكوره
المانزل طبعا دي مجرد امثله كل واحد
يشوفنا ثقته الفعليه ايه ويصنف يكتبها
بالتفصيل ولوحدك كده هتكتشف كوارث انت
بتعملها في المصروفات الاختياريه دي
تحديدا وهتبدا توقفها فورا انا شخصيا جيت
في شهر بتامل البنود بتاعه المصروفات
الاختياريه لقيت اكتر من 750 جنيه رايحين
على بند اشتراكات خدمات بس الفيديو مات
فليكس
ومنصات عربيه تانيه وانا كل يومين او
تلاته بدخل اتفرج على وثائقي واحد او فيلم
مثلا طبعا لغيت كل ده وسبت حاجه واحده بس
واحد تاني بياكل بره البيت كتير ومعتقد
انه بيصرف مبلغ صغير يكتشف نهايه الشهر
انه بيصرف تلت مرتبه مثلا على الاكل بره
البيت واللي اغلبه كمان بيكون اكل غير صحي
ومضر جدا كل ده لازم يقع فورا واحد تالت
عمل خط التليفون وفاتوره وبيدفع رقم كبير
كل شهر هو مش محتاج الباقه دي كلها لازم
يقلل الفاتوره بدل ما بيدفع 500 جنيه في
الشهر مثلا ينزل لمستوى اقل ب 200 جنيه بس
طب هتسجل الميزانيه ازاي بقى اما بالورقه
والقلم او مثلا تعمل جروب بينك وبين نفسك
على واتساب او تستخدم اي ابلكيشن بتاع
الميزانيه اللي يريحك ويناسبك المهم تستمر
في عمليه المسح المالي لحياتك كلها
الموضوع ممكن يكون مرهق ممل بس صدقني ده
هينظم حياتك الماليه وهيحطك على اول طريقه
تخلص من الديون بعد ما نعمل الميزانيه
هنقف على وضعنا المالي الحقيقي وهنقدر
نتحكم في نفقاتنا وفي اموالنا الهدف اننا
نهايه كل شهر نلاقي الفلوس اللي داخله
اكتر من اللي خارجه وبفرق كويس كمان علشان
نسدد ديونا لازم تكون نفقاتنا الشهريه اقل
بكتير من دخلنا الشهر ده اللي لازم يحصل
فاحنا هندخل على مصروفاتنا الاختياريه
ونبدا نقللها او نوقفها كلها زي ما وضحت
طب لقيت برده ان المبلغ اللي هيطلع بعد ما
خصمنا مصروفاتنا من دخلنا لسه قليل وغير
كافي ومش هيسرع عمليه تسديد الديون فورا
هدخل على المصروفات الضروريه وابدا اشوف
ايه البنود اللي ينفع نقلل الانفاق فيها
في بعض التكتيكات اللي ينفع هنا منها على
سبيل المثال ادخل على البقاله واشوف ايه
اللي كنت متعود اجيبه وينفع استغنى عنه
بدون ما يعمل لي ضرر زي المياه الغازيه
مثلا او انا ساكن في بيت او شقه كبيره
وبدفع لها ايجار كبير انا مش محتاج كل
المساحه دي وبالتالي ممكن استغنى عنها
واسكن في شقه صغيره بايجار قليل مثلا بروح
وبرجع من الشغل وبتحرك في عربيه الخاصه لو
ربنا فتحها علي شويه والعربيه زي ما
حضراتكم عارفين بتصرف بنزين وقطع غيار
واهلاك وتصليح فممكن اركنها واركب مواصلات
عامه مثلا او اشوف حد ساكن في المنطقه
اللي انا ساكن فيها وبيروح شغله في نفس
المنطقه اللي فيها شعري وما عندوش مشكله
تشاركه الرحله في عربيه واحده لو عملت
حاجه من الحاجتين دول هتوفر 50% من بند
مصروفات الانتقال من والى الشغل دي بعض
الامثله التوضيحيه ممكن تناسبك وممكن لا
شوف انت ايه اللي ينفع تقلل الانفاق فيه
من مصروفات الضروريه طيب عملنا كل ده
وعصرنا المصروفات بتاعتنا هل مطلوب مننا
حاجه ثانيه اه طبعا في خطوه مهمه جدا لازم
نبدا الشغل عليها الميزانيه زي ما قلنا
فيها حاجتين النفقات والدخل النفقات او
المصروفات احنا قللناها وتخلصنا من بعضها
هنروح للناحيه التانيه بقى وهي الدخل لازم
نزود الدخل ولو بشكل مؤقت لحد ما نسدد
الديون اللي علينا الهدف اننا نكبر الرقم
اللي بيطلع من حاصل طرح النفقات من الدخل
لان ده اللي هنسدد بالديون لو جيت مثلا
نهايه شهر وبعد تقليل النفقات لقيت
مصروفاتي 10.000 جنيه والدخل بتاعي 12 الف
جنيه فكده صافي الدخل 2000 جنيه المصروفات
مش هتقدر تعمل فيها حاجه تاني لانها
اتعصرت خلاص بس هقدر اعمل حاجه الناحيه
التانيه وهي سياده الدخل وبالتالي صافي
الدخل عندي يكبر وبدل ما كان 2000 جنيه
يبقى 5000 جنيه لو قدرت ازود دخل من 12
واوصله ل15,000 جنيه ممكن اقدر ازود دخل
من خلال بعض التكتيكات اللي ممكن تتعمل
هنا زي مثلا اني اشتغل وظيفه تانيه انا
كاشرف من عشر سنين تقريبا كنت داخل بيزنس
وخسر وفجاه لقيت نفسي مديون برقم ضخم
بالنسبه لي وقتها بنتكلم على 19 ضعف الدخل
بتاعي وقتها ولازم يتدافع في اسرع وقت
عايز اقول لحضراتكم ان الفتره دي كانت من
اصعب الفترات اللي عدت عليها في حياتي
علشان اسدد الدين ده حرفيا كنت بشتغل اربع
شغلانات في وقت واحد وفوقهم اكتئاب بسبب
الضغوط النفسيه اللي كان مسببها لي الدين
ده الحمد لله سددت كل جنيه في خلال 6 شهور
على ما اتذكر فممكن تزود مهاراتك وتشتغل
شغل اون لاين مثلا الحاجه التانيه اللي
نقدر نعملها علشان نزود الدخل ممكن تاجر
غرفه في الشقه لو ده مناسب او شقه كامله
لو قاعد في منزل طويل عريض طبعا مع تحري
عوامل الامان قدر المستطاع وكل البديهيات
اللي احنا عارفينها ومش محتاجينها اقولها
الحاجه الثالثه اننا ندور على الحاجات
اللي ما بنستخدمهاش في حياتنا ومركونه على
الفاضي في البيت ونبيعها في مواقع لبيع
الحاجات وممكن نعرضها على اصدقائنا وهناخد
فيها مقابل اكبر لانهم هيكونوا واثقين
فينا وفي استعمالنا للحاجات دي حاجات بقى
زي الادوات المنزليه اللي ملهاش لازمه ولا
استخدام عندك مكتبين بيع واحد واشتغل من
التاني عربيه اطفال بعد ما طفلك كبر وما
بقاش يرجعها هتلاقي حاجات كتير مركونه
وقيمتها بتقل وشغله حيز بلا داعي والقاعده
هنا بتقول ان سله المهملات الخاصه بشخص ما
تعتبر كنز بالنسبه لشخص تاني برضو دي كلها
مجرد امثاله زياده الدخل راجع لتقديرك
الشخصي للامور ومحيطك وامكانياتك والفرص
اللي قدامك وسعيك لها كده احنا اشتغلنا
على الجناحين بتوع الميزانيه عظمنا واحد
وهو الدخل وخلصنا التاني هو النفقات او
المصروفات وفضل عندي رقم اللي هو صافي
الدخل صافي الدخل هتبدا توجهه لتسديد
الديون بس بعد ما ندخل منه 10% ونحطهم على
جنب للطوارئ لانه لو حصل امر طارق خلال
رحله تسديد الديون واحنا مش عاملين صندوق
الطوارئ هنضطر نستلف او التاني ونفضل في
الحلقه المفرغه دي اخر ولو مبلغ صغير
هيفرق معك بعدين صدقني وهيديك مرونه
تتعامل مع النفقات اللي بتيجي فجاه
وبالتالي هتقلل احتماليه الدخول في ديون
جديده في المستقبل هنا بقى يجي سؤال مهم
ورئيسي احنا خلاص بقى معنا صافي دخل رقم
معين بيتوفر كل شهر هنسدد فيديو ازاي بقى
يعني ايه هي استراتيجيات تسديد الديون في
طريقتين مشهورين جدا لسداد الديون هنشتغل
بواحده منهم استراتيجيه الاولى هي كره
التلج سنوبول الاستراتيجيه التانيه هي
الانهيار الجليدي قفل لانش وخلونا نبدا
بالاستراتيجيه الاولى وهي كره الثلج ده
مصطلح صاغه المذيع الامريكي الشهير
المتخصص في الاستشارات الماليه
ويقصد بالكلمه هنا استراتيجيه البدء بشيء
صغير ونبني فيه بمرور الوقت لحد ما يبقى
شيء اكبر بنفس الطريقه اللي بتصنع بها كره
الثلج هنطبق ده ازاي واحنا بنسدد ديولنا
برده احنا اتفقنا اننا عملنا قائمه
بالديون مظبوط على القائمه دي ونرتبها من
حيث حجم الديون الاصغر فالاكبر ونبدا نسدد
الدين الاصغر ده واللي طبيعي هيتسدد بسرعه
بعدها ننتقل للدين الليبياليه في القائمه
وهكذا لحد ما تسدد جميع ديونك ميزه
الطريقه دي انها هتخلق عندك دافع قوي انك
تكمل سداد ديونك وتفحت في الصخره اكتر
وهتديك احساس بالسيطره على الوضع المالي
اللي انت فيه لانك شايف ديونك بتتساقط
قدامك سريعا وعدد الناس او الشركات اللي
بتطالبك بالديون بيقل مع الوقت عيب
الطريقه دي انك لو عندك دين رسوم الفائده
عليها بتزيد مع التاخير عن دفعها هتلاقي
نفسك بتدفع مبلغ اضافي لحد ما يجي الدور
على الدين ده وبالتالي لو عندك النوعيه دي
من الديون اللي هي بالفوايد فالطريقه
التانيه لسداد الديون هتكون مناسبه اكتر
ليك وهي استراتيجيه الانهيار الجليدي
الطريقه دي بتدي اولويه لتسديد الديون على
حسب اسعار الفائده وبالتالي احنا هنا
هنعيد ترتيب قائمه الديون بتاعتنا ونحط
الديون اللي تاخير دفعها بيضيف علينا
مبالغ جديده او الديون اللي عليها غرامات
تاخير لان تكلفه الدين بتزيد بمرور الوقت
وبالتالي التخلص من الديون دي في البدايه
هيوفر علينا مبالغ احنا في غنى عن اننا
ندفعها او تضاف للدين بتاعنا الديون دي
تعتبر جزء من نوعيه ديون انا بسميها
الديون المزعجه وهي اي ديون بتحط عليك عبء
اضافي سواء كان بقى عبء مالي زي الحاله
اللي ذكرناها بتاعه غرامات التاخير واسعار
الفايده او عبء نفسي ودي نقطه مهمه جدا يا
اخواننا ممكن الدين ما يكونش عليه غرامه
تاخير ولا فايده زياده ولكن مسبب لك ضغط
نفسي ومخلي حياتك جحيم مثلا بقيت مديون
بمبلغ معين لشخص والشخص ده بيهددك كل شويه
وبيهدد امانك الشخصي والاسري ومسوق سمعتك
بين الناس في محيطك وعمال ينهش فيك علشان
تسدد فلوسه ده دين له اولويه برده لازم
تبدا تسدد فيه على طول لانه هياثر على
صحتك النفسيه وممكن يهد كل اللي انت بتبني
فيه دول الطريقتين الاشهر لسداد الديون
شوف ايه الانسب لك وابدا نفذ على طول في
استراتيجيه ثالثه بقى احنا هنطبقها في كل
الاحوال واحنا ماشيين في سكه تسديد ديونا
بيسموها نطفه الثلج اوليك ودي اللي ما
يعرفش من حضراتكم بلورات الثلج اللي
بتتساقط في اشكاله واحجام مختلفه المقصود
هنا ان اي اموال اضافيه هتجيلك زي الهديه
مثلا او المكافات بتاعه الشغل او لو كنت
مصلي في حد ورجع الفلوس اللي عليه كل
الفلوس دي هتستخدمها في سداد الديون مثلا
لو حد من اصدقائك هيجيب لك هديه اطلب منه
بشكل مباشر انه طالما كده كده هيشتري هديه
لا يديها لك بشكل نقدي علشان تستفيد منها
بشكل اكثر فاعليه الهديه او المكافاه هنا
زي نطفه الثلج اللي بتتساقط بتكون مميزه
وشكلها حلو وبالتالي فهي مدفوعات صغيره
بتيجي لنا بشكل مفاجئ فهندخلها على طول في
خطه تسديد الديون مش عايزه اطول عليكم
اكتر من كده لكن هقول لكم كلمه اخيره بس
قبل ما اختم الدخول لحلبه الديون سهل
الخروج منها صعب زي ما انتم شايفين سهل
جدا دلوقتي تستلف او تقترض ولكن علشان
تسدد الموضوع بيكون مرهق وبياخد وقت
وبياخد من صحتك واعصابك وبيعطل خططك
وبيشدك لورا فافضل طريقه للتخلص من الديون
هي انه ما يبقاش في ديون من الاساس على قد
ما تقدر لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي يا ريت
تحكم لنا تجاربكم مع الديون لو تقدروا
ازاي اثرت على حياتكم وازاي تخلصتم منها
هتابع كل اللي هتكتبوه في التعليقات ما
تنسوش تشوفوا منصه مستقل هتلاقوا لينك تحت
الفيديو يا ريت لو عجبكم الفيديو تعملوا
لايك وشير وتشتركوا في القناه زي ما
اتفقنا واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم
عننا يمكن يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]